so you know what that means right
what he's a wanted fugitive okay
so if i find out that you're with him
you're gonna go to jail for a hard run a
fugitive he is a wanted fugitive
[Music]
hey sean
what's going on howard doss we are not
together tonight the first time no i
mean it's kind of weird you've got a
you've got a new job and you're on the
road quite a bit man i am i am i am i am
actually uh in the new york city as we
speak
coming to you from a hotel so this is
my guest for the episode right now
tonight
did does she have a name is that doris
that is uh
yeah give me yeah doris i need a good
we're in so i'm saying in soho so i need
a good uh
soho-esque type name you know something
flashy like maryland tatiana or
something
tatiana that's just top tiana well
tatiana looks fabulous
i've never stayed in a hotel that has
something like that so
obviously
there's a couple of them in here
actually there's two or three of those
just in the different rooms
in here so well this is kind of like us
just facetiming and hanging out you know
but like good old days so we it is we
should be able to do this you got
anything to drink there in that hotel i
do and i also want to apologize to
anybody out there listening type the
sound quality is not the best like i
said i'm having to do this remote i
brought a legit professional mic with me
only to find out about three minutes ago
yeah i don't have the proper adapter to
plug it into my laptop so we're doing
this off the good old
apple eye buds but because i'm in a
hotel i don't have my
bourbon whiskey
collection to choose something to sip on
we're not together to choose something
out of the studio you clearly have a
very nice collection behind you but i
had to raid my little mini bar
and i've got a
little bottle of negroni negroni it's a
nice do you have an opener for it
howard i i just forgot my adapter i have
everything else i need in life i just
forgot my adapter to make quality
podcasts you could go you you should
give it to tatiana she'll be able to
open it well i on the other hand do have
access to my liquor so i'm uh having uh
samo fitzgerald 15. 15. nice yeah this
is this is a solid bottle right here
this is right in the center of the
old fitzgerald profile wonderful
wonderful
brown elixir made by the people of
heaven hell so
yeah over the top uh the right side of
your hat there you got a whole
lineup of old fits so very good stuff
all right cheers to you cheers
all right these are my favorite to do i
mean i like having guests and guests are
fantastic
you know what negroni means in italian
shit dirty panties dude this is
wow
do you want to get another drink
nope
you sure
no i'm right by the bathroom here you're
gonna have to finish it dude that's ass
man yeah that is bad
yeah it's like somebody put like cherry
grenadine in a miller high life it's
just fucking disgusting all right here
we go let's do this i gotta i'll finish
it
all right so this is my these are my
favorite ones we're going to do some
news stories but first we're going to
talk about uh what's going on
on your uh new show
yeah man all right so
gosh we uh on patrol live uh we'll kind
of do a quick recap over last weekend's
episode some of the big things that
stuck stood out
um
probably to me
i don't know if i'd say that i thought
it was funny one of the fascinating
things to me about this show is
watching the difference in the type of
crimes different agencies have to deal
with and how they deal with them and
things like that and uh you know just
internally evaluating man if i was there
how would i handle this
well in night county nevada that place
is wild dude that place is like the wild
west and it is
the it is the second largest county in
the u.s geographically wise um and i
guess for the state of nevada from my
understanding it's like the poorest
county that's out there now it's very
very spread out
um i think prompt is the name of the the
main town that's within that county we
don't see a whole lot of prompt we kind
of see the outskirts of of prompt
uh
you know in the desert but there was a
guy that was he had a felony warrant for
his arrest and so the deputies went out
there to arrest them
they made contact with this poor
neighbor who's been sounds like
terrorized by this guy for years
and he tells him hey the suspect just
left a few minutes ago on his harley
well the beauty of having a you know a
three-hour live episode is you kind of
think that this incident is over because
they couldn't find them well then sure
enough an hour or so later we're still
live on the air one of the deputies
spots the guy on the harley davidson out
riding so they try to stop them they get
in this motorcycle pursuit
and it goes off of you know this little
two lane highway out to the desert and
they're riding on dirt trails and things
like that chasing a harley-davidson
and
yeah you obviously live in tulsa you're
very familiar with the city and i that's
where i've lived and worked at and just
watching
these deputies chasing a guy literally
in the desert with nothing but mountains
around
eventually the guy ends up having it he
crashes the motorcycle and takes off
running he's a very large man the deputy
is chasing him
and at one point with the camera cruise
there everybody is just walking
and the suspect is walking the deputy is
walking
the camera crew's walking behind him
because he can't bypass the cam you know
the deputy
and the deputy you know is just telling
them to stop and the guy's not stopping
and the camera behind it all you see is
just
i can't imagine how many miles of desert
and mountains and it's just
very interesting to watch lieutenant
shrimp may have spotted that suspect
they've been looking for remember his
name was kevin and he was driving a
harley he'd been wanted on a number of
outstanding charges they'd spoken with
his girlfriend earlier
we're
[Music]
kevin stop running you're not gonna get
away
i have no problem chasing you
i'll be east of my vehicle
kevin just slow down kevin
go ahead and continue south a little bit
past my vehicle we'll be east
kevin just stop
kevin
you're not going anywhere just stop
i'll follow you all day
eunice continue south so you don't have
to walk so far
uh
keep going south
go ahead make a left when you can
ready
all right so i watched that episode and
well as well and you're right that guy
that uh said he left on the harley i
guess had been terrorized had rented a
trailer to him he had stolen
the
he had stolen the i guess the power line
to his trailer while he was going yeah
they dug like an underground line from
one house hey that's more common that
people know and i'm talking about
everything from cable services
uh you will see people that you know
come up with some jerry rig version to
run
battery cables and stuff like that from
one house to another it's pretty
impressive what some of these guys come
up with and how to steal
utilities from somebody else but earlier
in that episode they were trying to find
this guy and i guess he was a fugitive
and i i assume it was a
dude you need to meant for that
dude i know you know i don't know how
many people watch this video on our
youtube channel or
you know on long crime but this is bad
man
they're going to get a kick out of my
face they'll make memes out of this
because this is terrible yeah you're
making some faces for sure but so they
this guy had a felony warrant for i
guess a domestic right yeah or something
like that yeah and his
i guess they went to a uh a residence
went to the door
made contact with the girlfriend's
father
um were able to find the girlfriend was
i guess driving by they made contact
with her got her out of the car and they
were talking to her about harboring a
fugitive and right one of the deputies
said um i don't
there was a report that you were seeing
with them today and she goes i've texted
her with him today i haven't seen him
and we always know that criminals never
lie right never they always they always
tell the truth
so um he he explains to her that
that she's actually breaking the law if
she's harboring them
we are back live in nye county nevada
with lieutenant eric murphy remember he
spotted that vehicle he believed it was
the suspect's girlfriend
that is her the suspect wanted on the
number
charges
[Music]
okay
so how long do you know we've been
looking for him
since my aunt told me yesterday you guys
were at the house okay
so you know what that means right
he's a wanted fugitive okay
so if i find out that you're with him
you're gonna go to jail for a hard run a
fugitive he is a wanted fugitive
i understand that
it doesn't matter bullshit it's still
warns
it's still warrants
so
the law requires me to put you on notice
so you're put on notice
if i find out you're with him you're
going to go to jail for hardware and a
fugitive
that's good because i i don't for one
second believe that people are telling
us that you were with them and you say
you weren't and you weren't i've been
here in my dad's house
you could ask a sister okay because
that's why i've been out with my kids
because i had to take my knees back out
to vegas to the airport because she was
out visiting for two weeks from
california and so i had my sister pick
me up monday night to bring me um
or to pick me up she picked me up monday
night so this way i could take my niece
cherish eventually
so let me ask you something okay i've
done this job for a long time okay
you just sat here and told me that it
was bullshit
okay
yeah
right
okay then why doesn't he just turn
himself in and get it squashed i don't
know because
my understanding
for what i'm not sure do you have you
have kids with him right
i mean i don't understand why he just
wouldn't get it squashed and let you
guys stop this torment
i mean it'd be easier wouldn't it
wouldn't it be easier just turn himself
in
because then everything's done now you
know what i'm saying even if even if he
is gonna go to jail at least he's gonna
go to jail and get it done what if he
what if he runs now for two years and
gets caught and then they sentence him
to two more years
so listen that's what i'm trying to tell
you i believe there are a number of
charges there that the suspect is facing
theft obstruction uh drugs we'll keep an
eye i didn't understand all that what
what does it mean when you get give aid
to like somebody like that what kind of
offense is that yeah basically if
there's somebody who is wanted and
you're kind of helping them hide out and
you know that they're wanted you know
you're purposely
uh obstructing the police from allowing
them to find this guy or you're lying to
them to send them in the wrong direction
you can be arrested for either you know
in oklahoma it can be for obstruction um
or exactly a kind of harboring or
fugitive is the term
that we use there it's not something
that's used a lot
i mean how many times have you like gone
all right i'm taking you to jail for
harvard and a fugitive sounds like some
bullshit out of a movie yeah well it's
it's man i'll tell you who uses is your
fugitive warrants units and like your
marshals you know u.s marshals guys that
are tracking people down from state to
state for
you know for warrants like in tulsa
we've got a fugitive warrant unit that's
partnered up with the marshal service
and the guys are cross-deputized and so
let's say you've got somebody who's done
an armed robbery in kansas city he's
wanted up there and they find out he's
hiding out in tulsa well those are the
guys that get tasked with trying to go
find them that's what they call the task
force huh that that's that's it here's
your test
everybody's task force according to the
street bad guy they think everybody
doesn't wear a uniform it's task force
but
uh so then you know that's and that's it
so then you know it's a it's a way to
you know what you try to do is you talk
to people and let them know hey you can
be arrested for harboring a fugitive a
lot of times it's family members of
these suspects there's girlfriends you
know stuff like that and they're not
necessarily bad guys and they don't want
to get jammed up and something somebody
else is doing
and they're like man i don't want to get
arrested for harboring and they end up
kind of helping you out now there's a
whole lot of people that don't help you
out at all and kind of send you on a
wild goose chase
well um one of the guys that you and i
know david bice bryce bryce yep he uh he
worked for the task force the fugitive
task force for years he and he said
there's two places that fugitives always
go
you know where that is
mamas and girlfriends baby shit man so i
mean
he he said all he had to do was camp out
on mama's house for three or four days
and they'd show up yep absolutely that's
the way he would catch them well that
was pretty what other kind of uh stories
did uh do we need to recap from
man you know the the the other two
things that really stood out of both
episodes
um to me were actually our wanted pieces
that we did
we had one each night with one friday
night one saturday night
one of them took place uh here in new
york city actually um in the bronx if i
remember correctly and it was a guy
about 6 30 in the morning he was walking
crossing the street he was a grocery
store worker on his way
on his way to work and these guys hit
him in the middle of the crosswalk with
a car and literally sent him flying and
knocked him unconscious and
you see in the security camera these
guys stop and one of them gets out and
runs over to the victim when you're
watching it you're thinking oh my he's
going to check on this guy no he's not
checking on him he robs him he ends up
stealing like his fanny pack off him
runs jumps back in the car then the car
returns a few seconds later and not
because they had a change of heart and
wanted to make sure this dude wasn't
dead they ended up rolling him back over
and going through all his pockets and
stuff uh you know getting some more
belongings off of them and so as of you
know when we did the show last weekend
that guy was actually still in the
hospital recovering from his injury so
it's 6 30 a.m and this grocery store
employee is heading to work when
suddenly a black sedan sends the man
airborne
now someone from inside the sedan comes
running over to the victim
but not to see if he's okay
to actually rob him
moments later two men from that same car
returned not because they had a change
of heart but to see if they missed
anything the first time
they turned the victim over and check
his pockets before finally taking off
watch again it looks like the driver
intentionally swerves onto the sidewalk
before plowing into the 39 year old
grocery store worker leaving him
unconscious
as the victim lies helpless the suspect
grabs the guy's fanny pack
and then these heartless thugs actually
return to the scene of the crime
apparently searching the man's pockets
for any loose change
now let's take a look at the suspects
all three men are black with thin builds
and each of them appears to be in their
teens to early twenties
the car they were driving was a dark
four-door sedan which looks like it
could be a hyundai
it's one of those things i think for
the public to see that should honestly
should piss you off um you know to watch
something like that and then the other
wanted deal
which were able to report good news on
uh this one was an 80 year old guy
who was a widower he had come home from
playing golf and somebody was waiting
for him outside the house to rob him and
this guy hits him in the head with a
rock forces the old man inside of his
house makes him open up the safe and
inside that the safe
the elderly gentleman our victim
actually kept a handgun in there and the
suspect takes the handgun
he's been threatening our victim with an
ice pick now he has the handgun as well
the victim says man i've got another
safe out in my garage where i've got
some valuables they go out to the garage
smart for this victim because he
actually tells a suspect i need some
more light and tells the guy to open the
garage door so
you know the big door the overhead door
and so the suspect actually hits it and
this 80 year old man and this is where
it all gets picked up on the ring
doorbell camera from a neighbor across
the street
this uh our victim runs out of the
driveway and the suspect is chasing him
from behind
and it gets basically right up to this
ring doorbell across the street and the
suspect is trying to shoot him with his
own gun and the suspect is literally
racking the slide trying to make it work
and
pure luck that the victim actually kept
his handgun unloaded in the safe so
there was nothing in the chamber nothing
in the magazine because just in the
video you see off the ring doorbell the
suspect tries three different times to
shoot this you know older guy from
behind
um so just a horrible horrible thing to
watch
the good news is and sorry from still
rambling howard but this guy our suspect
ended up getting caught down in arizona
um i think in in mesa if i remember
correctly a few days later i think his
name was armando dangerfield
no shit his name was dangerfield
literally uh no respect you know rodney
dangerfield but yeah this guy this piece
of shit guy was named armando
dangerfield he was arrested
down there and
i dug a little bit into it in november
20 november 2020 our motto dangerfield
and another guy were arrested for four
armed robberies home invasions uh there
in phoenix including one of them where
they terrorize a 75 year old woman
and i don't know if they're out on bond
i don't know why this you know shit bag
is basically out on the street but the
good news is you know the guy has been
arrested and he's now in custody and
what i think is great about the show in
addition to showing you know what the
officers are doing each night uh you
know something that's really important
obviously for i think any successful
community for a successful police
department is when you do have citizens
and you know their involvement helping
the police department out and vice versa
and so by showing these wanted segments
or the missing segment we also do it
allows the viewers
to try to look for these guys that you
know are out there on the streets
running around that you know they might
not know
but because they watch this show they
might go hey man that guy you know he's
he's staying with this girl right down
the street you know that type of deal
well let me um okay so back to
this is new you've got a new partner on
there it's you and dan curtis is on
there this is this is the this is the
crime of the week by the way i'm putting
this in for crime
yeah the one the whoever made this is on
the wanted list actually i think i think
did you get it out of the fridge i think
it's supposed to be on ice dude i think
that would help
that would help i don't know it's like
natural light
but hey how's the chemistry going how's
it working with dan again i know you
guys just probably fell back in like he
never did anything adam curtis in there
curtis seems he seems like a wonderful
human being curtis is great
listen curtis is a perfect fit he's a
natural uh you know his background and
everything you know that we talked about
on the episode with him just a week ago
he's a natural and all this this is uh
this is easy i love watching the guy
work any any teleprompter work there's
very little of it but
he he's so natural at everything he does
up there and he's just jumped right into
it so
uh it's great having him part of this
thing as well are you using the you're
using the stain same production company
right
yeah well it's uh it's called half moon
productions
they're kind of a
big fish entertainments who did the uh
the previous show
half moon is a product kind of a
spin-off production company and from my
understanding is that particular
the half moon productions is kind of
focused
strictly on this type of programming you
know probably in the law enforcement
criminal justice world whereas big fish
they're using that for the other side of
projects they want to do if i understand
correctly
well lydia i mean it's great to be have
you back on the air it's been fun
watching it i've been watching it on
philo the only thing is is that philo is
like old tv because when you watch it on
there and they put a commercial up you
can't fast forward that's brutal they
want you to watch the commercials but
with that said i haven't watched many
commercials lately and one of the
commercials that was on there and i
think they time it because
of what time of day you're watching
they're kind of pegging you for a
certain demographic
one of the commercials was for a thing
that we use you said pegging i know
pegged me well it even gets better so
we use a particular product in the
hospital that we use instead of a foley
catheter for patients and it's used on
female patients and it's called a pure
wig and what's called what a purewick
we lovingly refer to it as a blue canoe
because oh yeah you've discussed that
before on here yeah yeah so the blue
canoe
actually has a home device that they're
using so i was watching this i got home
from work early the other day and i was
watching it on philo and they pegged me
for a
i guess an older lady with incontinence
and they put up a purewick
home ad on there and the curious thing
is is that i can get that for three easy
payments with no finance costs
very nice
what's one of those costs
i think it was 3.99
but that comes with a full suction and
everything else that you need on there
so gotcha well i will say this you know
what we're when the show's happening
it's live
when you know dan is told in his ear
uh you know everybody gets mad at dan
that we have to take commercials and
everybody acts like this is the first
television show they've ever seen that
has a commercial in it and that you know
there's a way that networks
pay for everything that happens and it's
a big part of it comes from commercials
so it's a necessity
and when you have advertisers that are
paying the money that they're paying
they're going to get their air time you
know it's just how it works hey people
complain and think it's dan's fault when
he says sorry guys i got to take a break
we're going to a commercial and all he's
getting is something in his ear from a
producer that goes hey you've got 30
seconds we got to hit we got to hit a
commercial you know he's just a
middleman yeah i mean we've gotten so
used to like netflix and hbo and all
that stuff that we aren't watching
commercials and then when they come on
we're like what are these things yeah
why why are you bothering me we remember
tv when they only had three channels and
it went off at night you know yep
that's not the way now so people are a
little bit spoiled all right so i want
to talk a little bit about some news
stories that are coming up and really
what i want to talk about is i want to
talk about theft and i know everybody
gets pissed off about theft uh
everybody's been a victim of theft um
some people have had mountain bikes
stolen out of vans that weren't locked i
don't know
a lot of people those are a lot of the
nuisance things that go out there lots
of people have who own businesses have
had stuff shoplifted from them
and i mean it kind of goes up the ranks
theft is one of the hardest things i
would assume for
you guys to police
no
without a doubt it is
um one just the sheer numbers of it that
happens you know the police officers
especially if you're talking businesses
i mean
gosh you go on
you know burglaries from vehicle
burglaries of residences things like
that minus
an alarm going off or somebody watching
it happen and kind of giving you
real-time information we're never there
when it happens
um
and
with the the large number of shoplifting
whether it's these mobs that run in a
bunch of people are taking stuff at one
time or if it's individual shopping you
know shoplifting that happens
you're getting a lot of jurisdictions
now that aren't even prosecuting it and
it's just it allows people to can just
go right back the next day and do it
over and over again and listen we've
there's been new stories across new
stories and news stories across the
country of
you know whether it's walgreens or cvs
or other stores that are just literally
closing down because the theft is so
high
in their particular areas and listen
these are businesses they are in the
business of making money so when people
are taking stuff for free in large
quantities
they're not making money so they're
going to shut their doors well i read a
interesting statistic from the
uh retail association of america and
they say for every billion dollars of
retail business
seven hundred thousand dollars worth of
merchandise is stole yep stole and
that's a country term stole
it's stolen
so um that works out to about seven
percent so that seven percent has to go
somewhere so it actually probably
ends up coming out to the consumers are
actually paying for it but you were
talking about shoplifting now and that's
something that i mean we see these smash
and grabs the news likes to talk about
those somebody running in grabbing a
six-pack of negroni's and running out
right
they they'd run it back in and apologize
i'll tell you that
um they'd give it back and that's the
store to give them money can i can't get
my money back on these i stole these um
but the thing that's
that's really
completely interesting about this as a
retailer you like if somebody comes in
and you see them they blatantly walk in
they steal something walk out
every corporation in america just lets
them go
yeah yeah
sorry go ahead with the exception of
some small business owners and one of
the things that i would like to bring up
is we have a friend named dirk
and he owns a liquor store
and he caught a shoplifter and the
shoplifter got a little indignant with
him and dirk got arrested because he
punched him
in the face which
is the right thing to do the guy was
stealing from him you know
right how's that line up in the law why
was he arrested for this well you know
hey listen the laws are the law you know
and that's what the police officers have
to operate in we have a lot of
discretion um you know on a lot of
different things that go on we see you
know
obviously we do you have to otherwise
every person be thrown in jail or given
a citation for you know every little
minor thing
but when you have obviously you know
involving a physical injury
um oftentimes you've got you know it's
not what we call a victimless crime you
have a person that is a victim
and
we've got to operate with whatever the
the state statutes are or city
ordinances so
if you assault somebody and
doesn't mean you're not going to beat it
in court when you go to court but if
there's probable cause for an arrest the
police have to make an arrest just like
that now hey listen and you know one
thing we've always tried to avoid here
on cocktails and cocktails is kind of
getting to the political side of
anything with with this stuff but
you know here in new york city there was
a highly publicized thing where
a uh bodega owner you know ended up
having to protect i don't remember he
was i think he was getting robbed it was
either himself or somebody else and he
ended up killing the guy that was in i
think armed with a knife
and he was originally arrested and
charged and it just got he was just
dismissed a few weeks ago
uh but there's the video that just
happened in southern california earlier
this week
where a guy that you know exactly i see
you smiling the guy that old like 80
year old man that owns us or working
this liquor store owns it and dude comes
in with a rifle
and
the owner sees him on the surveillance
camera parker on the side and coming up
and he blasts his ass when he gets in
the door and you hear the dude screaming
he shot my arm off he shot my arm off he
winged him for sure dude good i mean and
that's the thing so
going back to what you're saying these
large corporations they obviously have
insurance um you know they try to
establish policies because they don't
want any of their employees
being hurt and you know they're also
looking at the civil liability side of
things so if one of their people tackles
somebody and someone gets hurt the way
unfortunately things are they're gonna
that suspect will turn around and sue
the company well there was there was an
interesting case about dollar general
yeah well let me let me just finish that
thought real quick so we were talking
about like dirk or this bodega owner or
some of these smaller those are
family-owned businesses
and those are people that's how they are
paying to put food on the table that's
how they're paying their mortgage that's
how they're taking care of their kids
um and so for them it's like you're
you're taken out of their pocket you
know these these businesses the people
that are working there you're not taking
directly from them um but when you're
taken out of their pocket it's personal
and
that's just uh you know why you see i
think more fight in the people as we
were talking about like dirk and some of
the other people i just mentioned
well i i that guy has never shoplifted
from him again so i mean that's a it was
an effective deterrent uh but like you
were talking about corporations and
their liability what happened in dollar
general i guess somebody was stealing
from dollar general what in the hell you
want to steal from dollar general i
don't know but somebody was stealing
from dollars hey listen i think the
threshold you know is 500 or a thousand
to have an actual felony okay so that's
a lot of shit you got to carry yeah well
here's the other thing a guy stopped a
somebody that was shoplifting blatantly
stopped him the guy turned around
and fought with him the
the employee of dollar general grabbed
him he was a larger guy ended up having
a heart attack ended up having a heart
attack at work dollar general had to pay
out
366 000 to the employee for workman's
comp related to stopping
the guy that was shoplifting so that's
how they ended up saying all right now
this is too much of a liability we'll
just let them steal so much of it it's
cheaper to let them steal than try to
protect that but like you were talking
to bodega owner so out in california
this is the this is what i was really
smiling about i guess the felony
threshold out there was like 897 dollars
so this guy in his convenience store
went through and marked everything eight
thousand and ninety or eight hundred
ninety seven dollars everything was like
you see price tags you see like snicker
bar eight hundred ninety seven dollars
twix bar eight hundred and ninety seven
dollars min
and the thing was if you go up to the
register he gives you the real price he
gives you a discount right but if you
take it
felony immediately he said it
immediately cut down on all his
shoplifting so that was it that was a
kind of a genius way to go on there but
okay so we're talking about this stuff
and we're one of the popular things
nowadays is people are putting let's say
you got a construction company and
you've got a trailer and you put your
tools in it right yep well people are
using technology i mean back in the day
it was lojack right you could put a low
jack on your car drive around you were
able to find that
i don't know how you were able to find
that i never remembered lojack but now
people for the
low low price of 29.99 you can buy a
couple of air tags and drop in things
and so people are dropping air tags and
some of their valuables and they're
going and confronting people
which sounds great on paper right
as long as you get the police involved
so we we are we are two of the founding
members of a very nice scooter gang
right
that is correct
a guy had a scooter he put an air tag on
it
got stolen he went there
confronted the guys
two of them came out beat the living
shit out of him sent him to the hospital
and he's still gonna get his scooter
back
so what do you tell the public on those
things about like air tags what's the
best way to do it if you find your
property just
have the police go help you how's that
go yeah listen anything you know if it
ends up in a pawn shop and that's a lot
of times what happens on valuables or
stolen in their pond
you know if you're able to track it back
there same type of thing call the police
the police typically will come out put
what they call pond hold on it so it
can't be sold and you'll oftentimes get
your stuff back and then the police
department works with the pawn shop to
try to track back to the person that
pondered
um as far as things like your phone's
being stolen because you know you can't
track a phone you know with find my
iphone back to somebody's house and
stuff like that
always if there's criminal
uh
you know involvement call the police and
the police will come out on it you're
just like hey listen my my scooter was
stolen you know i've got the the um
what the hell is the tag called air tag
air tag it's got an air tag on it you
know the gps device on my scooter
um
call the cops you know let them come out
and you know try to do what they're
supposed to do and hopefully they can
talk to the people try to get their
their way inside or you know potentially
get a search warrant and then they can
go inside and search as well but that's
something you people's just safety-wise
should not do on their own and i know
it's hard because you know you're angry
it's personal that's exactly it's
personal feelings
you want to beat somebody's ass
everybody feels violated when they get
their shit stolen you know absolutely
and i mean even if it's even if it's
something small you know but there's i
mean there's people
checking doors so i always lock your
doors sometimes i haven't done that so
i'm going to be the public service
message man i'll tell you right now
there's a guy
there's a guy from my gym and our group
texts at the gym today this morning
um he he came out and his car was
missing it was his work car
and he left it unlocked and don't know
why but he left his keys in it and his
wallet overnight and he lives in the
suburbs of tulsa in a nice area
but that's people just drive through
neighborhoods and they check doors
doesn't matter where it's at and his
company car was stolen just last just
last night so less than 24 hours
jesus yeah that that's some bad stuff um
when you think about
a lot of these crimes i mean most of
them are kind of petty i mean you dude
you're really not enjoying that drink at
all dude it's not good well
next one we'll have to do in person just
so i can save your ass from drinking
that stuff yeah
but when we talk about theft there's a
there's lots of different types of theft
out there and i mean we get i mean we
can talk like the bernie madoffs and the
people that do like corporate scams and
ponzi schemes and all of this stuff but
one of the things that's pretty popular
nowadays is that people uh
will set up gofundme sites oh yeah is
this that female
yeah she's
up in new jersey is this one we're going
to talk about just the uh
so people know this is you know this is
how and i don't have like an outline of
like hey let's talk about these things
want it to so
natural that's it you're talking about
the female that met like the homeless
guy and they were talking about yeah
yeah her name is kathleen mcclure what a
piece of shit her and her husband or
boyfriend or whoever it was they took
trips and bought all kinds of crap and
yeah put the facts out there
okay so she uh went to social media and
went to gofundme and actually i think it
started on um
instagram she said hey i met this kind
homeless man who helped me with the
problem and come to find out he's a vet
you know or
everybody loves vets if you don't we got
a problem you know i mean everybody
should love it
and i'm going to stop you on that really
quick
it's bullshit well i've spoken about it
numerous times both of my parents career
military people my brother my sister
both in etc you know all the love in the
world for every person that has served
this country for sure
and tulsa we have a panhandling problem
and where i get off the highway at the
head to the house there's a guy that is
out there
that walks with his sign and talks about
being a vietnam vet he has like the two
or three years he was in there from like
68 to 70 or something and it drives me
bonkers although i'm thankful if in fact
he wasn't because you know i don't know
if he was or was not
but just he tries to use that strictly
for for sympathy only to give you know
people throwing money as way so we love
our vets
and so forth but go ahead well you it's
it's kind of like the sally strothers uh
like the she had the the pet thing that
she did there marshall was on there it
it
it elicits emotion in you and from that
emotion you're like oh hell i gotta give
them some i got to do this right and
this is exactly what this mcclure lady
did so she fabricated this story that
she ran out of gas and this homeless vet
saw that she was struggling and gave her
20 for gas because she didn't have that
and that she really wanted to do
something good for him and try to make
his life better and ended up raising 400
000
yeah that's a bunch of money from 14 000
people
and uh like you said so she decided her
and her boyfriend were going to go ahead
and just live the high life with that
money they were going to take it they
were going to uh go and have some
vacations they bought some cars they did
all this stuff but the thing that they
didn't do the guy that they brought in
that was supposedly the culpable home
homeless vet that was supposed to be
getting the money they didn't give him
any money so he was like this is
bullshit their bullshit just turned on
him just rolled completely over on him
and set out so that's she ended up
getting sentenced for 27 months in
prison and she has to make restitutions
back to that but that kind of that kind
of shitty
con man stuff is the worst
it is it just pisses you off man you
know and you hit it right there on your
head it's like it's the sympathy
you know
we as you know we should be sympathetic
obviously
um you know compassionate
it's part of being a human
but when you're using that stuff
strictly to try to take advantage
especially when it's a made-up story
that you can benefit yourself
uh that's just really shitty i mean heck
we've seen people or heard stories you
know people who have claimed to had
you know cancer and things like that and
did the exact same thing they started a
gofundme deal to get people donating
money and and in fact
there's no cancer you know they're
they're not cancer stricken at all
they're just
greedy little bastards well and the part
that it does that is it makes you it
makes you suspicious of the next person
yeah so you're like oh no i got burned
on that one so someone who actually
needs the money so you're actually
robbing from two people at one time so
you're robbing from me and you're
robbing from the potential giving i'll
do in the future okay so the next thing
is is that you get you were you were on
a gun
task force
so your job was to get illicit guns off
the street correct yeah i'm going to
keep harping on this for this entire
episode
if i this right here negroni was out in
people's houses i would take this too
just like illegal guns
that that's what they should give to
people who are caught stealing dreaming
that's their punishment drink one of
these a day
okay so one of the things that they've
done that's been pretty popular is gun
buybacks yep did you guys ever do any
gun buybacks no um
no we did not so any guns that we seized
once it goes through the the forfeiture
process you know the courts determined
this gun was illegally possessed
the case has then been
closed or judicated
we have a contract with a
a company within tulsa county
that has a mass
incinerator that everything goes to
so that's we do the same thing with all
our drugs but all our firearms go there
and just get burned uh but we don't do a
buy back we don't we don't sell our guns
back out you know that we seize you know
as a money-making issue for the tulsa
police department or the tulsa county
district attorney's office we also don't
buy guns from the people the public
well i guess in houston they had a uh a
gun buyback did you hear about this no i
did hear about this we
i stay on top of current events howard i
know hey and i read all the police stuff
man yeah i
i read lots of news and i love reading
about this and all the nasa star stuff
that's pretty cool as well but so when
uh you you want to you won't tell them
what happened in houston man i don't
they ended up buying it i mean it was a
significant number was it like six or
eight hundred or something like that
right so what happened was is they have
a gun buyback and it's um there's no
questions asked she's bringing the guns
in and they give you a they don't give
you cash they usually give you a gift
card from between
uh 20 and 200 bucks just depending on
what kind of gun it was or how much it
was well somebody some somebody with a
very entrepreneurial spirit decided that
he was going to go ahead and turn in a
bunch of guns
uh the only problem was is he didn't
have real guns but he had a whole bunch
of 3d printers so okay i did not hear
this one i did not hear this oh oh yeah
yeah so this guy got online
and he loaded down the free available
schematic
for
a 3d printed gun and he printed out
8 thousand dollars worth of gift cards
and sold them back to the houston i mean
they were fireable they could actually
you could actually shoot something with
them so he decided that that's i guess
his printing cost down there was
somewhere around 15 to 20 dollars so he
was like okay i got a buyer i know who
he can sell these guns to i'll just go
ahead and print
so that
to me that's a little bit of theft from
us yeah which which is the next thing
that i want to talk about during the
pandemic there was a lot of money that
floated around lots and lots and lots of
people got money um if you're a private
individual they'd send you a check
if you were a business and had employees
they had a very popular program called
the ppp
which was the payroll protection program
and what that was designed for is like
let's say that you owned a restaurant in
our neighborhood
and you had employees
and you were forced to close or shutter
your doors and only do takeout
in order to keep your employees working
the government gave you money to pay
these employees even though they weren't
working as much so our economy could
stay afloat you know who didn't get
those
checks
uh
who
police nurses
i did not get any time off in fact i had
to say exactly that's my point yeah you
you uh you were you did not get any a
single dime you earned your money you
were out there hustling that's for damn
sure right every time there was we were
definitely essential you can put that
put that in half for sure but the uh
thing that's amazing about that is i
would see these memes of people going
hey i just have no concept of time i
haven't been out of my house in six days
and i'm like all i have is a concept of
time because i'm having to go to work
every day well there was a couple that
decided that they wanted some of this
ppp money
and not because they had
a
business but because they like money
which i mean i understand how we like
money so these two were out of la and
they can they went ahead and devised the
scheme which was to set up these
multiple
businesses that didn't exist
and the government in its haste and
during the pandemic when they were just
trying to keep everybody surviving
sent money to them and they ended up
getting about two and a half million
dollars worth of money for
fraudulent employees and fortunately
kind of going back they started to check
to see who was there
and they found out that they had made
a lot of these companies were basically
had the duplicate employees on it had
duplicate social security numbers and
they were like ah this isn't working out
so they found this couple in la they
arrested this couple in la um they had
three children uh the oldest one was 14.
um they arrange them and as they do
sometimes they gave them bail
so they gave them bail
they immediately
took the money that they had left and
went to montenegro you know where
montenegro is
it's not montana
no it's next to montana yeah it's north
of greece so it's a little it's a
non-extraditable country
uh unfortunately for them no
so they thought they could go away but
the most
i mean it's it's heinous i mean
everybody kind of does stuff fudges a
little bit but i mean stealing from us
that's what they were doing they were
stealing from the american public right
they were stealing in fact that money we
didn't actually have probably came from
a deficit so well we're paying for it
now that's for david
they took that money and they stole from
us and went to montenegro and the thing
that i thought was
so selfish about this wasn't the fact
that they had stolen from us
but they had left a note for their
children
and they had left their fucking kids
what a piece of shit
yeah and they were saying this is the
hardest thing that we've ever had to do
and we're greedy selfish parents
right when we got to montenegro they
bought three homes there
and they actually i'm sorry i said two
and a half they ended up getting 18
million dollars worth of it
they had two and a half million dollars
left
so on a case like this
this is this is a big federal case right
okay dude
do i need to doordash you something man
so i'm not gonna so let me really quick
yeah a vomit bucket
um
but this thing
so
my wife
we have a small fridge that's in the
room and we have brought some of our own
food items so we had taken
a lot of the items out that were in this
thing it was like champagne and all this
stuff we had taken it out and this was
one of the bottles i had taken out maybe
an hour earlier so
listen maybe it is better or colder on
ice because it's like
almost room temperature now it is it is
bad like i'd rather just drink nyquil
hey we're having a dinner party we're
all gonna have negronis how do you feel
about that oh dude i'm not coming do
people people drink those i i've had
those cold made by a good bar and they
they're not the best okay sorry go back
to your story so they these people left
their kids fled from another country
right so on a local level how can local
police help with that do they do a lot
of i'm sure that they have to work with
the federal employ the federal
authorities and then it becomes an
international case to get them
extradited how's all that shit work well
most likely from the very get-go that's
gonna be a federal investigation you
know something that involves money like
that that's not gonna be handled by a
municipal police department or the
sheriff's department that'll be handled
at the federal level probably the fbi um
you know and i don't know if there's you
know irs for tax stuff or you know
treasury department is gonna be
something like that that's up there most
likely the fbi though
um so it's already at the federal level
and then you know if it's an
extraditable country they've got
contacts or interpol and you know stuff
like that uh you know all over
that will work together to try to track
somebody down and get them them back
here to the us where they could you know
face the charges
so there's really i mean basically the
whole concept of this is is that very
rarely do thieves get caught is this
this is my assumption well it's not only
yes very rarely they get caught
and you look at the magnitude of how
many times just take we'll say a
shoplifter
how many times they do it until they get
caught and then they get caught
you know again going back to what i said
earlier a lot of these places they're
just not even being prosecuted you know
whether it's the store that just says
hey i'm not calling the police you're
not welcome back here and they kick them
out or it's the police they get there
and they go this doesn't make the
threshold you know
you know or here's the ticket whatever
it may be and so you get these repeat
shoplifters that just over and over and
over again are stealing as long as they
don't break the threshold of a felony
that day which varies from you know city
to city
some of it's pretty high you know it's a
thousand bucks some places so it's like
man you can walk in and steal a
800 jacket
and uh it's a ticket and then you get
caught you're going to get a ticket and
you're walking down the street you pop
at another store and still a 600 jacket
you get caught you're going to get a
ticket let go so
um it's a major major problem for sure
well
i i heard of a a
shoplifting ring i mean they weren't
even shoplifters i think a shoplifters
are people who are being kind of sneaky
these are one of these smash and grabs
but you and i we have daughters so we've
been to a one of the most expensive
stores that we go in with our daughters
is called ulta
yo
makeup man there you go
you have never seen such a little bag
that's so pricey yeah i remember the
first time i took both of my girls
i was like what the hell i was like yeah
you just get whatever you want i mean i
had no idea i learned after that trip
it's very different than the you know
the maybelline section at target
or or walmart you know when you walk
into alta you're walking out with
a lot yes
so i guess there were a couple of uh
three ladies walked into an altar and
stole 14 dollars worth of stuff and just
walked out
and they were prosecuted but i mean you
you you're talking fourteen thousand
dollars that's that's a big crime man
that's huge but then you know even i
said the monetary number it's still not
gonna most likely get people prison time
you know that's so unfortunate well i
know there's a local retailer in town
that has a uh
and you know of this has a squad car
that pretty much is camped outside just
to deal with shoplifting tickets
yep i mean i mean
what a drain on your resources you can
actually be out
helping people you know
yep absolutely you know and i mean
if we're both talking about the same
store i'll say at the walmart i don't
know if that's what you were referring
to or not but the walmart i can even
tell you that 207 south memorial yes sir
that's the one i was gonna say a
memorial yep 207 south memorial and it's
they it is pretty much a police officer
that's this permanent assignment is
basically there because of the number of
shoplifting that problems they have
there or the other type of problems for
the people that show up there and this
was that walmart and correct me if i'm
wrong or i could be wrong but i want to
say it was like one of the
highest theft walmarts in the entire
country like the number one one or maybe
it was the number one for having the
most police office you know police
related incidents called to or something
like that
um and yeah it's
going back to what you're saying there's
other things that police could be doing
because of uh shoplifting unfortunately
they're they're kind of stuck there
so i mean
is there just so much theft that it's it
would just burden the court system too
much to prosecute all these folks
i i mean
if you ask the prosecutors yes
but the law is the law you know and the
prosecutors that
what i disagree with is these places
where they're doing that or just saying
hey we're not prosecuting that you know
uh you know here in new york city the
the pros the the new d.a here
made some changes on what they were
going to prosecute or what they're going
to do well you know the
the laws that are on the books or the
laws that are on the books right um
you know they still need to be
prosecuted and if you play them down and
stuff you can't just flat out say hey
we're not going to prosecute these types
of the quality of life i think are the
terms they use you know open urination
people that are peeing in public you
know loitering that are that are hurting
businesses shoplifting things like that
i mean
get the laws changed at the state level
then if you guys don't want to enforce
them
or you know because the police are still
going to get called to them we're so we
still have to go to those calls and
handle them and it's very frustrating we
have to go to these calls you're trying
to help with the business out or trying
to help a person out
and nothing gets done with it once it
gets beyond us
so at that point you just get like i
mean
i i guess that's crime fatigue people
just don't file anymore they don't call
the police they just deal with it huh
well that is what happens people or they
start taking things into their own hands
you know and that's where things can
also get dangerous so
um but that's why i think we're seeing a
lot of
you know plight
um you know in
cities across the country i'm talking
from coast to coast big and small
is because there's just a lot you've got
a lot of police officers burned out
under manned i mean i just saw an
article
in the tulsa world today when i was on
the flight i think tulsa is authorized
for
940 officers and we have 780
so that's a big difference man i mean
that is a big difference you're talking
almost what that's close to 25 percent
right understaffed
you know and we're on pace to have or a
record number of homicides this year
yeah and that's the stuff that that's
the stuff the police need to be dealing
with is homicides and
rapes and
violent crime that kind of stuff getting
guns off the street not so much
somebody's stealing a 20 toaster you
know yep well
we're going to come we're still going to
come to it man if people are stealing 20
toasters we have to come deal with it so
that's the truth well this was very
informative to me man and uh i'm glad
that you had uh
a nice drink
this is terrible dude i i i just want to
go brush my teeth right now is what i
want to do i know what i'm gonna get you
for christmas too so there you go no
all right brother
cheers
[Music]